So, with some logic and some algebra, we can come up with two equations for this
problem. We used the individual amounts from each account to equal the total
amount. And we used the interest rates and those amounts to get our total
interest. Now that we have two equations, we can use them to figure out how much
was invested at each rate. I'm going to show you how to solve the system using
substitution. I think it's easier than elimination because I can either isolate
the x in this first equation or the y. If I subtract x from both sides, I can
solve for y. So y would equal 10,000 minus x. Now that y is solved for, I can
replace this y with 10,000 minus x, this is my substitution. I've made the
substitution in this line, the I distribute the 0.08. Multiplying by 10,000
moves my decimal point right four places, so I get 800. And then I have minus
0.08 times x for the second term. Next I subtract 800 from both sides. I have my
constant terms on the right, and then my x terms on the left. Next, I combine my
like terms and I get negative 0.005 times x. Then, I divide by the coefficient
of x to get x is equal to 2,500. But we need to make sense of what this means.
Let's look back at our problem. X is 2,500. Well, that's the amount of money I
invested at 7.5%. Knowing this, I want you to finish out the rest of this
problem. How much was invested at 8%? Write your answer here.